live
okay hi everyone we are continuing our
design review of discrete computation
for version 13
of orphan language
and where have we got to last time we
looked at some very lovely functions
last time halfway down into geometry
okay
all right was there anything left over
from this uh earlier stuff
don't think so
okay
is this all in the head branch build now
because i've got some things i'm doing
which could make use of this
charles
um
yes but we are still um you know trying
to think everything so but yes he's in
the master branch
in headmaster
right
okay
now i don't think the last time we had
looked at
this binary tree and so on thing
had we yes because it was not
charles it wasn't quite there right to
look at
well is in principle is not there but
there is i mean we kind of agree that we
should just support it so it's just a
matter of implementation there's pretty
much not no documentation or changing
design but that's not right that there
will be data structure documentation
i'm sorry wait a minute this is just
saying that graph of that data structure
will work but presumably there is a
property of the data yeah there the
graph property of data structure
right how are you going to document
the fact that this thing does the
conversion
so if you open the documentation of
graph there is already a table there
showing
the list of
objects
right so what we've done for these
omnivore
kind of functions like a lot of our list
plot functions have become omnivores
is that we list the types and how it's
treated i know i see this i don't have
to go back up up up up up up up up up
there i'll stop the where it says 12 3
which is obviously not right
why does it say 12 3
that's not a good way to present this
come on just say data structure don't
don't this is silly
just say entity entity dot dot dot
the name entity right
right yes
yeah sorry well the thought was first is
that we you know we wanted to put an
illustration we haven't yet finished
that the point was you know we wanted a
three-column on the you know
the first column have illustration
essentially to show you quantity which
in this case is usually a graph or
molecule i don't think it's i i think it
can be the second thing what i would do
is say entity dot dot dot
and then what you should say in the
third column
is what it does like for molecules it's
not a molecule object it it will say it
will give you the bond backbone of the
molecule
right
well no this is not finished but this is
this is what we've been doing for the
plotting functions like how is that
object interpreted
yes good that's what we need but i'm
just saying i think you should give the
the symbolic template of the object like
entity dot dot but christopher you were
about to say something
no i mean i was just going to ask if
the term ent is ever used anywhere
because otherwise there isn't really a
point of like
yeah you know saying and it's kind of
pointless i think anyway okay so we've
got a plan for how to do this
um
yeah
that's nice i just wonder if there's
anything else that graf should should
eat
what about a mesh
why can't graph eat a mesh um probably
not because there is no unique way to
canonicalize and we have we introduced a
mesh connectivity graph for that i know
okay and i assume that graph points to
things like mesh connectivity graph it
doesn't
it should it can't point to everything i
mean maybe should point to that one but
literally we have no no i know 40 to 50
percent of the functionality of things
that produce graph
in the whole graph framework so yeah
fair enough i know it but it shouldn't
point to that but it should point to
things where
like somehow they're they are
i
it's
uh you know diplomatic connections to
other areas of the system
i mean arguably another area of the
system i think that part of what we
intended to do is in the scope section
to give um
you know to show
because this scope is mechanical it's
not really application driven
yeah it's explains the scope of the
functionality and this is one important
sort of new constructor way
by the way i i'd like to comment on that
in
uh the all the sparkle stuff
doesn't that also produce graphs and
what is the what is the interconversion
between these
well as far as i know i did i don't
think that it was a function i think
sparkle who could turn the graph but yes
it's related to graph database and you
should
okay the other thing is text structure
shouldn't it eat that
i don't know whether that makes any
sense
that probably doesn't make sense but at
least it should be diplomatically
pointed to here
as another thing that produces graphs
that you might not think would produce
graphs
okay in any case i'm sure it's on the
guide page presumably it's on the guide
page yes things like text structure
i mean these lists
definitely should be on guide pages yes
they should go up golf construction yes
okay all right
let's keep going here
by the way
i wonder whether there is connection
between
the uh trees documentation and the data
structure documentation the tree data
structure documentation
i don't know whether i don't know
whether every low-level operation in the
tree data structure is reflected in some
high level operation
i think this is the wrong group
okay all right okay all right let's keep
going
okay so we had renamed this what did we
renamed it csg region
okay
um
okay so had we finished going through
the the stuff about these csg regions or
not
yes
okay and and what is i mean so csg tree
and bvh tree
would be what now those come
from they are the actual tree structure
and how do they oh wait a minute that's
not there
no
yeah we haven't yet added the page the
page so
the thought is essentially several of
those low-level data structure in
geometry which is quite oh i see icic
those are part of the data structure
okay so another thing that i don't know
whether you're doing you're aware of in
documentation now the
the
multi-jointed see alsos which can point
to things other than other functions
right you're using that stuff are you
no what are you talking about we don't
even know about it multi-jointed sea
ulcers have never been
multi-jointed i haven't okay i've never
seen a multi-jointed see also
even on a postcard
oh for goodness sake okay bro this
probably happened on some private
discussion no it was not private it's
just you guys don't come to the monthly
documentation meetings no
maybe somebody should maybe some
representative from your group should be
coming to those i mean we are on
t new dock nothing was announced there
right oh goodness sake okay you need to
track this down
with is brady here i'm i'm here yeah
okay so you know what this is do you
know what that we're talking about here
you talk we're talking about sea also
that point to formats and everything
else right and brian was doing a huge
you know reverse engineering effort to
add
those okay
yeah apparently nobody communicated with
roger's team about this which is kind of
infuriating if it communicated to t new
docs everybody would know doesn't
specifically need i mean there's other
people that produce besides us all right
so make sure that happens and i mean for
goodness sake let's get a a round of
this i mean there's now ways to do that
that's the right way to reference for
example a data structure
you see what i'm saying this will be
yeah
i know and entities and other things
like that so they're called
multi-jointed
no they're not i just made that up it's
a terrible name yeah they had something
like a robot
yeah they had some other name brady do
you remember the other name
no okay
multi-type
yeah that would be reasonable multi-type
see also
it's a question from lou on our live
stream about uh graph databases this is
the wrong group to talk about that neo4j
and so on we are already working on a
bunch of that we already have a bunch of
stuff related to that
in our
uh
yeah we already but i don't think that's
that's not
so far as i know relevant to what
charles is doing right
it's different different problem
yeah well not quite well
what is depend on the point of view but
i think
we probably don't want a different group
it's it's a different group that that
and it's the wrong time so yep
okay
all right
reconstruct regions from point cloud
data what is this
okay there are two kinds of things here
so let me you have to go to the pages
but so region fit it fits primitives
okay so for instance in an ar
environment you typically want to fit
for instance a plane to be a table that
you can set things down on type of thing
this is what this one does
it fits individual primitives
let me understand the relationship
between this
and uh
you know in a in an image processing
finding image lines for example images
so the input there is image i understand
point data this is point data so this is
point cloud data or point data i know
that but the question is should there be
a generalization i mean should that be
similarly for an image we would like to
we've tried to get that going for image
a general function like this for image
um in which case it would be called
probably
image fit let's say
no that's not right because region no
what what's coming hold on
i would have thought that this should be
called point cloud fit
because it's actually fitting no it's
fitting regions
i mean you're talking about
data yeah but what do you mean where's
the input data
e1 p2
those are points
yeah
right but it is
in our naming convention shouldn't that
then be fit region since what's coming
out is a region not what's going in
but what would you name it then point
cloud fit region
or point cloud region
no we need a natural point cloud region
we need to drill with point clouds
point fit region i mean we have let's
see
we have things like list point plot 3d
yes right
this is kind of an inverse
not really an inverse but it's uh
it's in the family of this point plot 3d
yes sort of yes
i mean i would be
actually point fit region is not
terrible
not great but not terrible actually
i'm thinking about let me think
yes so we're saying
so we also kind of
you know keep that in that family of
region feet region convert because
there's a street or family you of you
know
region from construction to fit or to
convert where you know what does region
convert to
essentially it's convert between
representation so you can take a disk i
know but it eats regions and produces
regions
right this doesn't eat regions
[Music]
but we're also exploring the the
potential of extending it so to actually
cover all the way germs
other than just points
no no
the model space what kinds of region can
it fit
it is like two but that's different from
can it eat
yes
i mean could it eat will it one day be
able to eat lines i doubt it
all right let me ask this question this
this reminds me no it will
this should if it's something that we're
going to have yeah this is this okay let
me remind you image graphics
is an example something vaguely like
this
right which eats images and gives
graphics
sure
and we remember it because you know
image graphics i'm not confused about
which way around it is it eats regions
it gives eats images and gives graphics
yeah
that's why i think your name is not
totally bad actually it's it's
it's sort of it's along those lines
i mean we can't have full sentences in
names i mean no i know i know sometimes
do but
point
point fit region point fitted point
fitting
point fitting region
should it have should it have find in
the name
like find out
i mean is is this enough i mean because
i guess we have find for for when it's
sort of uh
you know
when it's sort of approximate or maybe
if it's local approx local optimization
or something or if there are multiple
possible solutions
probably start with find right like find
point region which is wrong because
the point points is points are regions
you know regions can have any dimensions
so
okay well what's an analogous thing i
agree that find is not a
terrible so
well
you know maybe i'm looking i'm looking
on the same thing but you know one one
one point of keeping region at least
around was essentially to not actually
lock the design
right in term of you know this case
where somebody can give you a you know a
bunch of lines
and they say find a cylinder that fit
those lines
right
so there is those generalities you know
generalization why don't you say find
if you think you're going to generalize
it that way just call it find region
and give it a bunch of points or you
give it some other primitives
that sounds really general yeah i don't
know fine region doesn't sound i mean
maybe i find region fit or something
find fitting region i don't know i feel
like it needs to have a word like fit in
it
yeah
find region fit was an earlier name it
says like that's too many mind fitting
region fit is already an approximation
so
and also we have all the you know linear
regression feet and so so we kind of
kept that in that same style
bob observes not a live stream that if
if our language was based on chinese
rather than english we would be making
up kanji all the time
yes yes
probably
well i was so proud of figuring out that
thing
um
wulan this um
the fact that there's a thing that wulam
which sounds kind of sounds like like
language
is
tungsten wolf
has a version that is pronounced like
that
and tungsten has its own
its own um uh
character
say that again tungsten wolf
tungsten wolf
okay so if you translate tungsten wolf
into chinese
there is
um you know they're a definite country
for those they're different what are
they called in chinese they're not
called country that's the japanese name
they're definite characters chinese
characters for
um
for tungsten
they that was one of the last
standardized things they put in all the
ones for all the elements
up to some point
and there's one for wolf and there is
some kind of pronunciation that is
something like woo lan
which is kind of like a wolf language
sounding thing
um
so that almost has a chinese character
well it's two characters two characters
i think it's two yeah okay the question
was how does this relate to circle fit
what does this relate to i mean can you
just run like question mark star fit
star or something yeah what does it do
what does circle fit do
circle fit seems to be a special case of
that function so
okay that's good
oh it's by santa who was commenting on
it
okay
well i wonder whether it does whether it
achieves the same thing so does it
achieve the same contracts about what
it's minimizing and so on um so this one
they're probably minimizing they're
doing a least square regression
probably yes the same so the what region
fit is doing is essentially doing a
ransack
method which is kind of standard
techniques and then at the end we do it
in you know
linear fit
to minimize the distance so you should
probably give pretty much the same thing
okay
um
[Music]
okay so
and there's another one called line fit
apparently
oh wow
we should look at these
yeah there's a question here i mean
okay
what does line fit i see it returns an
actual line primitive what does what
does the proposed find region return
the same thing so it's returned actually
the line in this case also an infinite
line a circle within a circle so it
actually returns a geometric object
and why are these in quotes
given that they're actual primitives
i think those are the second argument
when you want to specify what type of
region you want to get back right but
why aren't they just the name of the
region
i mean why do they have to be it's the
same like with bounding region like with
bounding region you say quotes you know
minimal sphere or sphere or you know
whatever like i mean and also stuff like
plane in there
but in this case we can probably add i
mean we are still updating the question
but it's probably not the name you know
much pretty much the
third column there so it's possible that
we just keep the so except for line
where we return an infinite line which
is different
ah well that's a good reason to have the
quoted version
could you return just to i mean you
might want to return the ordinary line
not the infinite line
with with boundary you know with ends
right wouldn't that be useful
um in some cases but it's defender for
you know how to bound it so it's you
know there are several choices but yes
okay but but
okay so what we've got here
look
this is
okay
i i have to say i think fine fitting
region or some such other thing
is the best name for this given given
your
goals for it
i mean fine fitting region
what's wrong with that name i kind of
like that name
it is finding a region that is a fit to
the thing you have given as input
i'm not sure we use the word fitting
anywhere we usually just call it a fit
don't we
yes find region fit
but find region fit is more obscure
because
what the other fit
functions i mean region fit would be
completely in line with those names that
you saw in the function repository line
fit yes i know but that that's not the
same thing
linear model fit what does that do
it fits a linear model so it returns a
linear model
[Music]
well i admit that most of these fit
functions do return the thing they say
i think it's honestly i mean i think
that
region fit probably is the consistent
name it's just that it does sound a
little bit strange
all right
um
there's no square an association with
the center
wait a minute
there's no square there's a square here
what's
yeah
this seems like a useful function by the
way
very
but now
my question is
okay in an abuse of this function so
how much of an abuse of this function
would this be
to find
i see this is this is to find
a geometrically described thing it is
not to find a fit you know polynomial i
mean you if i fit a bezier curve to
something am i not effectively fitting
you know okay how would i otherwise okay
let's say i have a bunch of random data
and i want to fit a bezier curve to it
how do i do that right now
um
so we are planning to you know add
actually support for curve in 13.1 on
the next coming version
but yes you should be able to
you would have to set up the parameters
and then you would have to um
yeah but if i if i want to find a
polynomial fit i i just say find fit or
whatever and i can find a polynomial fit
to something i'm just wondering do we
have existing bezier curve fitting no no
okay fine so this will be our bezier
curve fitting right the the the
bezier curves themselves have a
parametrization that's made for
user interfaces
if you see what i'm saying
there is a fitting too which is baked
into interpolation that solves an
interpolation problem that is literally
a fitting oriented problem
for bayesians and nurbs is that those
are basically user interfaces you design
the convex hole of the curve
you know so there's a kind of like
correct interfaces to those
look the concern that i have here is if
people end up using this a bunch to fit
lines
and things this is a very weird name
you know in other words somebody's doing
some elementary
i mean i don't know whether this is
well but you know the whole point is
it's returning a geometric primitive
right i mean if you're just trying to
fit a line
i mean i guess you could use it if you
just want to plot a regression line on
top oh that's what sander had done here
nicely rather nicely look at this thing
he's got what he's got is an epilogue
here
that's kind of cool
i mean yeah because honestly right now
doing that with i mean you can do it
with stuff like find fit but you have to
write out the equation of a line and if
you do terrible linear model fit linear
model fit honestly is kind of weird and
like you always have to give it your
data and then comma x comma x yeah then
you know
we should we should put something to
look at the workflow for the fitting
functions because it really is pretty
terrible right now
the in other words
yes
yes that's the whole regression world
that's needed attention way more than
support of quantities and [ __ ]
and less than time series
okay
but is that something that's on the near
term list roger yeah but if we do time
series we do time series we're doing
time series
yeah that thing you put there in a
second place i would call a model
structure and a neural net is a model
structure which in second in which
second place
the model
you know where you say what you you know
if it's linear you just give a set of
bases but if it's non-linear you give
the whole expression with variables in
the place where you wanted them to be
fitted
and
that is a model structure and a neural
net is an example of a model structure
yeah but that's a very general concept
and i mean the fact is
you know fitting
a you know
regression line to some data
fitting you know being able to plot
a fit along with data is a much more
basic thing and i think we should look
at that workflow before we solve the
absolutely general problem
maybe we can actually solve that stuff
for the fitting functions we have right
now before we start building new fitting
functions
am i making sense
it seems like part of the problem with
the design or like i mean
okay
at some level it's nice to have super
general unified fitting functions like
this but then also
i i don't know i mean they're different
cases for fitting where
like through
having one function yeah like the like
that if you just want to put a
regression line it feels weird to be
calling a function for fitting a a
region although you know crazy no no no
much sense that's that's
i mean it's very confused what if you do
a regression line you do a regression
line if you fit the primitive
like you get point data in the world
like point cloud data that's a different
thing
no exactly right but you can fit a
regression line i mean it's the same
mathematically if you just say line is
the second argument the region fit it's
it will give you a regression line
right and and that's fine but i mean
it's just sort of i think that's kind of
slightly the weird thing is that really
there could be one unified function that
basically does all of the the
or all the fitting that returns a
primitive let's say although maybe you
could even unify with things that return
your polynomials i don't think you want
that right because you don't want it no
exactly that that's what i'm saying i
mean this will be no
huge we have many many many many fitting
functions and they vary in their
workflows we can fit the distribution we
can fit a stochastic process
we can fit
a a point process we can fit all kinds
of things
and the the nature of data and the
nature of models vary
so sure but but i mean right i'm just
saying that basically
just in terms of talking about these
other fitting functions i think this is
fine but it's just uh
you know but some people they all look
the same they all take the data in the
first argument and the model in the
second argument
but there is also the there is also a
matter of goal right and you know and
the the goal defined with technique and
the level of fitting as well as you know
look the quality the thing right now is
very straightforwardly stupid right find
fit does not return there's no way to
get find fit to just return the formula
you have to retype the formula that's
dumb
and perhaps it could be fixed just by
having a property or something
am i making sense
do you know what i'm talking about yes
just
okay
and i suspect that is an easy fix and i
think we should discuss it in some other
meeting maybe an lcc meeting and just
take a look at that issue and see
whether there's an easy way to do it
before we before we dredge up the giant
monster
of you know new model mechanisms
this may be a really straightforward
thing to fix that function is quite old
and was built before some of the modern
frameworks that we have for properties
and so on yes so brady can you get that
on an lcc meeting agenda please yes
okay
um
let's see
the comments here about sandra's asking
come on add weights
can i add weighted data for these points
here oh this time no
but is that in the plan i mean that
would work presumably to say weighted
data there
yes there's you know weights you know
normals there is a lot of other
parameters you can ask right so okay
um next question i mean is there an
operating form of region no
okay
why not
because the heavyweight operation is the
fitting
right
so what
i mean it doesn't matter it's just a
syntactic issue
right i'm asking
it's i mean it can be built but i mean
was that vintage
that's the whole point it's the
advantage is to be able to say
region fit of circle
map it over a bunch of data that's all
oh well not a big deal
[Music]
i'm not sure it's a good idea i mean i'm
just throwing it out
okay but let's look at this function
okay so this function
all right so
perhaps what
the right thing is the string names
where as a courtesy it can accept the
symbols i suppose
does that make sense yes it does
okay
i see so this is a multi-point so the
first argument can either be naked
coordinates is that correct
yes
or
it can be
point primitives
okay and then then in the future those
could be line primitives and things like
that
yes
this is a nice function
so i've got another question the
something that this should relate to is
and probably link to is things like
circle through
you're aware of that function right yes
yes
you wrote it oh okay
there are more
constructors
right but i mean in
but this will presumably agree with that
function
yes now all the points are on the circle
yeah within the exact
okay what about polyhedron yeah do we
have polyhedron
no let him make any so no let's let's go
to back to the design document so we
have two other functions that do a so
this is a single primitive and this
this is like having a parametric model
all of these
um primitives are sort of constraints
you know they have a small number of
parameters right okay the two other ones
that come down there poisson mesh and
concave whole mesh are
that's nice we've had a we've had a wfr
function that i've used extensively i
think it's doing that okay
that's a thing written by
chip hurst i think i've used it
extensively what is it called it's
called
just remember what that's called i think
it's concave hole mesh
it might
be oh non-convex hull mesh
okay seems like a longer way of saying
concave whole mesh
well is it in fact concave or i mean no
it's not cold but it can be it can be
con
well yeah well well the term of concrete
whole is by say really pacing not well
defined right i mean it's not unique but
i say
so
also it might not be concave right no it
might not be concave which is why
non-convex seems like a better name well
it could be it could also be convex i
mean so calling it non-convex does the
same problem
it does
well we can look at them because they
have sort of their own they reconstruct
with using sort of different mechanisms
so the results you get are slightly
different
so this one
you know essentially
you need basically um points with
normals i thought you needed normals
didn't you yes you need normal if
there's no normal we
we compute normal but the input there
doesn't show the normals what is what
does it mean plus on surface what what
does that mean what this means
it means that we know the gradients
basically
um what the hell does that have to do
with possible like personal equation or
poisson yes so so then you take the
divergence of that
and you get a poisson equation
it's laplacian equal to something on the
right hand side boy this is confusing
because people talk about poisson
sprinkling which is the inverse
operation to this well everyone has oh
well you know we pass on processes and
point processes and
all right okay it's all very fishy it's
all very
well
okay
so you know that much friendships
okay but any case so the point here
this is a mesh constructor
that
is doing what it's effectively solving
poisson's equation somehow i mean come
on think about those as charges or
something or what what is the what is
the sense in which it's solving
poisson's equation
think of them as a great as a as a
well as a
characteristic function with that
wall
the the gradients the points outwards or
does it point inwards i don't know which
they point one direction consistently
right so inward so essentially if you
really think about it it's you know you
are trying to find actually the
indicator function
where you know at you know
you know it's constant everywhere except
that the boundary so you don't wonder
you have the gradient
so essentially if you think about this
it's kind of in this square minimization
of your you know indicator function the
decreasing should be equal to the normal
and that can be you know easily
equivalent to the you know
laplacian right which much of the
different
the divergent boundary so so listen i
have been a fairly serious user of
non-convex hull mesh okay so i can tell
you that it's sensitivity parameter it's
fairly important let you come to that
next that's concave hull mesh it's a
different i know i know i know i know i
know i'm i'm
jumping ahead to that okay
i see
of the specified parameter that is that
the sensitivity parameter basically
um right we don't call it sensitive
parameter for us so it's actually the
alpha shape where alpha is the size of
the ball
from the reconstruction technique
okay
well you should
you should not call it you should say
something like
i bet this is the same type of thing
here that this is a ball size we need to
illustrate that charles this we need to
iterate on that we need to see that the
alpha how alpha relates to those circles
this is totally obscure this has got to
say this is somehow the the granularity
of something
we are working on that you see below the
details we kind of you know are still
working on that trying to explain
exactly the cause i know but i'm saying
what i what i suggest you do
is
let's see
scale size parameter or something
something like that
i mean because this reminds one of like
you know when you're computing household
dimension for example you're putting
balls over a thing
am i making sense yes yes
it's amazing we still don't have we've
had endless people written them the
thing that estimates i mean we we've now
got for the physics project endless
dimension estimators
which we probably should package in
some kind of dimension estimate thing
for points
and graphs
does that make sense
yeah
and then
so if you go spelunking in the function
repository you will find a whole bunch
of different of dimension estimators
with different methods and so on are
they consistent
in terms of the results they give yeah
um well there's whole papers about that
jonathan has written a bunch of papers
and various other people writing papers
about that the answer is in the end for
these hypograph things
the incredibly straightforward dimension
estimator that i came up with years ago
seems to be actually the best
and there are much more elaborate ones
that are more sensitive to all kinds of
issues
and best is to find how
most robust
and and has good convergence and so on
i mean it's it's really straightforward
and it's really based on it's just
looking at the you know
the volume of gdc balls of increasing
sizes and looking at their growth rate
it's very straightforward thing
you know we should have a dimension
estimate function it's silly not to
um
okay but but here
i'm not keen on the name concave hull
mesh
because i understand that convex hull
mesh makes perfect sense
what what are these things called in the
literature alpha shapes
convex mesh tool and alpha shape those
are the two common okay well we're not
going to call it alpha shape
i didn't even know an alpha i've heard
of alpha shapes i didn't know alpha
shapes were just con
okay i think alpha is the one over
radius in those balls or something like
that right
well maybe we need a different kind of
name altogether i mean
it's given that we're having pus on
meshes which are
not okay what is this mesh really
it's a mesh
that is approximating down to some scale
size
yes
roughly yes
but it's a hull
i mean that's the important thing it's a
hull
i don't know whole seems
not the best of names to me
but hull is important because it's the
exterior boundary of the thing
yeah but hold means
i mean we have affine holes we have
linear holes we have convex holes we
have conic holes i know but hull means
the outer boundary and that's what we're
getting here we're not approximating the
whole thing we're approximating the
outer boundary which is different from
region fit which is attempting to fit
all the points presumably
is that correct
in this case let's just see the boundary
because you can actually have an actual
hole inside so it's not basic
[Music]
so what do you mean so this is the
boundary it's a hole it's no you can
have a hole inside yes
wait a minute what are you saying a hole
or a hole
um i mean you said outer bond away we
may have inner boundary it's what i mean
so yes it's a hole but we can have holes
inside
the object
i'm sorry charles is one of these places
you can make a donut
there
yes
you could make a donut though is the
point
yes but that doesn't have a hole
no you can't i mean
we should use we should use voids okay
so this is the confusing 3d thing
there's holes in the sense of
topological holes like in a donut
then there are voids
that are inner
voids
in a region
and so they're not the same
voids and holes okay i was imagining
more of an annulus than a torus so
you can have a 2d donut let's say with a
void in the middle of it
right
this is a typical example of a use of
the non-convex hull thing you see this
object
yeah so that was a graph
which was done with graph layout
and then this is
the
the filled in
boundary and i think there are other
yeah see there's a good example now now
i assume that your non-convex hull thing
would would be able to do this too
should be able to right
yeah can we get that some of that data
would be useful actually trivially it's
click to copy
and guess what
when you click to copy it
and then you it actually copies it
paste it then there it is
oh graph reconstructed surface okay so
that's another function there well i was
going to ask i mean when is that
reconstruction taking advantage of the
edges or is it just looking at the
points
i am not sure
let's look at graph reconstructed
surface i can't remember because if it's
using the edges then this is probably a
totally different
mechanism
yeah i i think it is not that
sophisticated but let's take a look
[Music]
huh
oh you know it just uses this
i probably rely on the fact that you
know it generate the layout from spring
electrical and rely on those points so
yes that's right right we look at the
top detail
so it's kind of analogous but it's it's
i don't know it's removing triangles
instead of edges or something i i don't
know he's probably drowning it dilute
triangularization
but closeness point no i mean you can we
can look
but i think okay so you guys will look
at this and this is a good sample if you
can reconstruct that that's a nice thing
and and the default thing that i was
doing there
the common thing that i've done is
that's obviously some opacity been
applied right
to
um
i'm sure this one is probably the same
thing right this is also one that has
the reconstruction included
aren't these cool
no
anyway
um
okay
well maybe there could be a more general
name for this that the concave
i don't know like if it was just
something like uh
you know
something for taking point point clouds
and making a mesh
well it i mean we we cannot go that
general right because it depends on the
technique we use to actually reconstruct
right like this graph construction
surface depends highly on the spring
electrical so it's uh
well but given the graph embedding it is
what it is right exactly so
but listen the term reconstructed
surface seems like a generic term that's
being used
yeah
and that's also sometimes called reverse
engineering
well yes but that's i think okay so wait
a minute so this is
but the thing is returning is a mesh
right
yes probably is it a boundary mesh
region
okay
i don't have a guarantee that it's a
solid object right so you cannot with
any boundary measure
wait is is i this is an off-topic
question but is boundary mesh region
ever going to support holes or is that
not what it's supposed to do
it supports holes yeah oh it does yeah
oh okay so then why
sorry i don't quite understand i mean
couldn't this
return if it's representing a hull right
no you see this one generate the surface
right you're constructively speaking the
surface
but if i think probably there's an
example downstairs you can depending of
your parameter alpha actually your
surface may not even have holes i mean
may not even be you know completely
closed it's what i mean
but we don't probably don't have it here
so
that's why you just want the mesh region
than the bonding mesh region
okay
so
by the way we're scheduled for another
design review which is a direct
continuation of this but we're obviously
not finished with this so that will be
pushed back by a few minutes
um
[Music]
okay so wait a minute
it's a very technical name i mean this
thing
is a generally reconstructive surface
from my points
oh boy
on the other hand you're saying it is
returning a mesh
name i mean could it have
um okay maybe this could it have the
word fit or no because
it goes through all the points right
we picked this name because i mean it's
a well-known
name people use when you do surface
reconstruction it's obscure it's as
obscure as alpha shape
look what about reconstructed surface
mesh
it's too general
here's the question i guess i mean if we
i guess maybe convex home mesh is
already another method for making a
reconstructed surface mesh but but like
you know forgetting about that if there
were other methods that we would support
we want them to be in separate functions
or would we want them to be method
options for this function
right
i think that's a that's a key thing
there's another extension going forward
let's say that we get other composite
forms i mean and in fact there is
another fitting to fit
these csg regions
but
going forward we'll have nurbs
regions and then we want to also
reconstruct nurbs regions
and why isn't that not just a second
argument to this why isn't the second
argument to this if this is a i mean
won't the nurbs regions also have
they'll also have a tolerance of some
kind i mean what about the possibility
of calling the the um size of the ball
tolerance of tolerance option and make
this thing reconstructed surface mesh
and expect that the second argument
will be i mean this is a piecewise
linear reconstructed surface
if it's mesh it can't return a nerve i
don't think no
well so there is two approach at least
when we're thinking about this right we
can have a general function
to just do reconstruction and then we
have a second argument or method option
to do that
right
or we can also
you know all we need in some cases like
here and produce special function like
for some mesh which is well known when
you want to do a construction right so
i've never heard of busan mesh so i
would never use bus on mission i
wouldn't know what it was and i would
think it was something quite technical
that's true like some people never use
my g or
no i understand that but but
reconstructing a surface
is something people i mean people use i
think we should get to so i think we
should get to that function okay i just
think it's a tad bit early for us to
introduce it
okay but hold on hold on we've already
got list surface plot 3d right we've
already committed to the surface word
for something which is somehow going
through a set of points right
list surface plot 3d
is the plotting analog of this function
is that a true statement
but different results yes
why is it different results because it's
using completely different techniques
okay but could we not get i mean if i
wanted a mesh that corresponded to the
output of list surface plot 3d how do i
get it
we don't have a function for that right
now but we should presumably
what would it what what would it in
terms of the structure of the function
how would it be different from this
function you give it a bunch of points
and it returns to you a surface of some
kind
right correct
right but then the question is that what
surface is returning you what's the
model behind right so that's kind of
important right
yes what are outliers because one of the
problems with list surface plot and list
curve plot
the 2d the curve you know the curve
analog
is that
it works pretty decent when there's a
dense set of points on a surface
and it works really badly when you have
a very wild
set of points or things that are you
know if you just regenerate a random set
of points for instance there's no there
is no actual surface you were just
testing it
um right okay look the problem is
convert concave hull
is completely does not tell me anything
about the method
you know it's just not a um
yeah i agree with you i i don't think it
tells very much either it's just uh
it's like how do people come up with
names for things i mean when you
actually think about sort of the names
and they're not functional you wonder
it's like how did anybody come up with
that name
right
so i mean
rich on our
uh livestream is suggesting
tight-fitting hull
which is yeah i mean it's a
i wonder if there's a
a fitter fitting hull or something like
that
again no i mean are we are we trying to
name just this method or are we also
trying to name you know the method that
returns nurbs stuff too
well i think nubs don't return a mesh so
that they're out of the game well okay
but i mean i guess the question is
well let's see if it's played five
different types of things you might try
and return or like you know methods you
would use etc do we want to have five
different functions or do we want to
have one unified function that's the key
question christopher i agree with that
and these are basically the things that
we're proposing here are kind of like
two methods that have
some recognition
right
the thing is people let's take me as a
sample user okay
i wanted to make these surface
reconstructions right for these graphs
my
you know i am not going to go and you
know i'm a non-expert
hula so to speak right so
it's something where
if there's a function that is called
surface reconstruction mesh or something
like this
reconstructed surface mesh or some some
such thing like that
i'll go to that function i'll just use
it and hopefully
we'll be giving us will be giving me
you know a reasonable method to use for
that
that is what we should be doing now
maybe we're not ready to do that yet
maybe we have to put in more specialized
functions first
i'm not sure although i have to say the
non-convex hull
you know thing that i was using
from the or this graph reconstructed
surface they work pretty well
well i mean let's just start with one
thing i think it works in 2d as well in
which case you don't reconstruct the
surface
right
right okay
and you know i perfectly agree that we
can have a general function to you know
to do that but we also have to balance
in in you know in terms of you know when
you really want
you know you are really you really want
to do a reconstruction you know a method
you know based on your data so it's
great so so then you use the method
option if it's that i mean clearly we
have many cases where people in
principle use method options although
they don't usually they usually use the
automated system
but
i mean sometimes there are dramatically
different things that you get out soul
versus reduce or something like that
yeah but in this case but it's not going
to be dramatically different i think
it's a little bit like machine learning
there's some name recognition here you
know i don't think it's
yeah and let me tell you in machine
learning i would like to point out that
the tremendous success of predicting
classify as opposed to calling them you
know logic regression you know whatever
it is
yeah support vector machines right we
don't you know somewhere inside there
it's it's nearest neighbor it's it's
whatever we just don't use that we just
use prediction classifier and that's a
very successful thing and so similarly
here i would have thought
um
you know
in the end okay so question there's a 2d
version there's a 3d version is that
true is there a 4d version of this
reconstruction
not yet because we don't have meshes in
4d yet which reconstruction
the one we're talking about here the
concave hull reconstruction
right i mean yeah it's possible to
generalize to generalize the end version
yes but we don't have a representation
right i mean you know notice that it's
list plot and list plot 3d
although we could principally
that had to do
that's an old convention because the
rendering techniques are so
uh you know we're so different
well they are still so different we you
know i i just remind you it's an awkward
fact about the universe at least as far
as we perceive it it actually just has
about three dimensions no but i mean the
point is is that list you know the the
the sort of graphics primitives and
stuff like that when you're displaying
things and when you're visualizing
things in 2d versus 3d are totally
different but for a mesh that you're
just computing with
yeah they're not i mean
fair enough fair enough okay but so
okay
we even have 1d meshes just two no i
know i've used them yes
um
all right so the point here is
should we go with this more specific
names that relate to
which is sort of
i think it leading up to what you're
talking about sort of a grander name
uh
but you know it reminds me of the of
some of the things in image processing
which are also not very successful where
they where they're very specific
you know
yeah like chambers of binaries exactly
people just want binarize
right nobody can remember what what the
that and it's up to us to automate
the methods
right
um
look what we call the general function
that returns a mesh
and it is a
you know
i mean what would it be bird fitted
something approximated
fitted mesh fitted what about what about
surface do we want surface and stuff no
well no we don't have a different
function yeah we do
because it isn't just a two in in 3d
right it's in 1d in 2d and 3d and
eventually you know nd
and i guess manifold or something is too
obscure yeah and it's it also isn't a
manifold
i hate manifolds
hmm this just one step away from disks
as i usually can
well you should uh jonathan has been has
been
trying to make this topos theoretic
version of the reels
that gets around what's that okay
but wasn't that exist already isn't that
the definition of it opposed by default
it's an extension of the wheels
this is some this is
i can't represent this this is an
attempt to um
i don't know
i don't know
no it's i mean there's
that
i can't i cannot usefully represent this
um
no but the thing is that manifolds are
great when you conserve from them but we
can't name things after manifolds
because we you know we represent things
that are strictly more general than
manifolds and we need to get
but so what what by by the way i mean
just
it's fine if these are separate
functions but what will the nurb
function be called it will end will it
are we going to put nurb and function
names are we going to call it yes yes
why don't we don't say that region
yeah
and then we have a second argument to
define what type of fit you know if you
want the nub you want the
mesh
so i'm sorry i'm sorry we can't have
region fit and fitted region well maybe
it could be in region fit but it makes a
bit too much stuff in that function
maybe unless unless fitted unless region
fit becomes fitted region
i think that i mean i think we're
talking about two key scenarios here if
we break it down so the first scenario
we started looking at this is when you
have
a a primitive that's kind of rigid like
a disk or a circle
is very rigid it can only represent
literally circles
okay and it's going to make that fit you
know it's gonna fit to that it's gonna
like snap to that model
then you have something that's super
flexible like a mesh and a nurb for that
matter
you know at least compared to a circle
it's super flexible
and they
the kind of way that you control model
complexity and other things has to be
different
from
you know when you fit the circle
right okay
and also the the circle case i mean the
this will all the corners will be points
in your data right and in the circle
case the circle doesn't even have to go
through any of your points
right then also the fitted one you know
we assume you you know you you know the
data is noisy on outliers right and you
know we have all the control for that
let me remind you that in this concave
thing it is not the case with a convex
hull there's a well-defined set of
things that you go through
i see what you're saying the concave
hull still goes through things it's just
a question of which things it goes
through
yes
yes
yeah i mean like in the alpha shapes you
know that ball says you know like is it
going to be inside or is it going to be
the at the hole
what about fitted hull mesh
because it's a hull because it does go
through the points
um
and what about fitted region for this uh
the thing is
the problem with region fit okay is that
as you just pointed out these are named
regions that you're fitting to i mean if
i see something like probit model fit
it's fitting a probit model to the data
right
but region is a much more general thing
a region could be a boundary mesh
you know
region
yeah
what this really is is it's a named
region fit right or special region fit
or something
right but but this isn't so what so
that all of these kinds of things
they have a certain kind of model
defined at the beginning here
yeah
in probability in statistics we had the
following situation like say with random
variables we had these parametric
distributions that are kind of rigid
like a circle
um
and there is an estimated distribution
right that gives you the distribution
object out you know if you specify it
distribution of a of a normal
distribution of something yeah some of
the data right
you know so data coming out data comma
model
then then we have also non-parametric
distributions so you can have something
called like a histogram distribution and
that thing basically swallows the data
you know and so estimated distribution
is the analog it's the one that is
fitting to a named known special
distribution so yeah yeah
which makes it seem like estimated
region
see that isn't quite right because it's
because the whole point is distribution
the distribution brand is primarily
special distributions like normal
distribution and so on it is not
histogram i i understand it has
you know histogram distribution and so
on in there as well which are the analog
of a about a mesh
yeah or kernel which is sort of the
analog of uh nurbs
you know this
has moved kernel
to smooth kernel distributions
right okay
okay so what we have
okay so
what we're doing here so one thing is
we're fitting to
okay we're fitting to a particular set
of of primitives
[Music]
but
are we in fact that thing returns actual
primitives right yes
what about something like that
but by the way okay this maybe relates
to this suggestion a bit
this is pretty similar both in what it
does and it syntax to um
what's it called bounding region i think
yes it has region in its name first of
all
yeah i mean we generally we've tried to
mostly we've ended in region when it
produces a region
and if it's more specific like mesh it
ends in mesh but if the summary name
yeah
and this
but this kind of makes it sound like it
could be a fitted region
instead of region fit
that's true
or maybe fitting region
true well i mean that's that look fitted
region
fitted mesh
or fitted hull mesh
does it matter fitted versus fitting
i just think
fitting is a little bit more whimsical
and weird
i'm not sure though for some reason
stephen you insisted on when we did
transform region you wanted it changed
to transformed
region that's sort of a distribution
and yeah and then the same thing
happened with region actually right
right but we don't want transform
because that's that's it is it is a it
is an object it is not the action of
transforming it right that's what's the
argument you gave them to
but so
okay let's look at fitted region and
fitted mesh
okay is there a reason to say fitted
hull mesh
or is it sufficient to say fitted mesh
i think fitted mesh i mean i don't know
what hulk adds to it
okay but then fitted mesh
would have a method option which would
give this surface plot 3d
type
fit
as well
the reason what's that i mean so so one
of them it goes through all the points
it goes through points
no i the the one for surface surface but
3d does not i know it does not go
through points that's why i'm saying the
whole part what on earth does hull mean
anyway
well hull usually means an outer
boundary of something because like a the
hull of a ship
i mean the name of the convex one i
think it was just the case that when
alpha is big enough you end up to have a
concave hole when alpha is big enough
you end up to have a convex hole
right and since you know for some most
of alpha you you know the object is
concave so people call it concave hole
instead of yeah i know but okay fine
but but
but
it has nothing to do with the hull the
ship which is an outer boundary right
exactly but but but most of the holes
used mathematically are these like a
linear hole means a linear combination
of things
a convex hole means a convex combination
of things
a conical with in a convex combination
is a is a sum
with positive coefficient that would sum
to one and a conical is a is again a sum
a combination of things where the
coefficients are positive
but it's always outer boundaries i mean
that's what that isn't that correct
that's what the saying the coefficients
are positive is a statement that you've
got to always be outside of these things
if i'm not mistaken
no it's because most of the times the
subject actually is full it's a full
dimension so you kind of always think
about the outer boundary right
but
it doesn't have to be restricted to the
outer boundary
i'm liking fitted nation fitted region
i do too
i think those are
okay so then the question is for fitted
mesh
do we have do we have an automatic way
to pick the alpha value
you mean for convex whole mesh at least
right now yes we have a method to
actually comp you know
how much yeah can't concave up we're now
calling fitted mesh yes right but you
can't even remember the previous name so
well
too many holes that we yes
okay but in any case but let's let's
make sure you know concave
i mean the fitted mesh doesn't mean by
default that we are going to use the
concave whole mesh method right it's the
general reconstruction techniques
sure it's a new function
concave whole mesh is a special case
i don't particularly care i mean i don't
think it's the right thing i don't think
that's the right thing i think it should
be a method option for fitted mesh
because i just don't think it's that
important of a right so so let's not
have a specific function for this let's
just have fitted mesh which right now
has one method
or two methods
yeah yeah and two methods would be nice
so we also kill um for some mesh no
in that case three methods
is plus or mesh just the same as fitted
mesh
but just a different method yes
yes you can also look at it as a
fitted mesh everything can fall in that
category just if you think you know the
construction so that's what i think we
should do especially since this doesn't
seem to have a lot of options to it well
sorry sorry one thing i didn't
understand about this pulsar mesh thing
i mean
does it require the normals because it
says it takes oriented points but i
don't know how those are represented so
poison mesh is a general technique
recognizing the whole community for
cosmo construction and in principle you
need to give it a you know oriented
point point with normals
but if you give us a set of points
without normal we can always estimate
normal so there is a standard technique
to estimate normals
right by taking the neighborhood and
reconstructing the you know the
corresponding plane and then you get you
know normals from it
which can point in
two directions then
i mean you have to
take
the two possible directions that you can
have a normal from a plane right
it doesn't matter right i mean for our
technical okay so the question here okay
we've agreed we're going to have fitted
mesh fitted region they're going to have
method options the question is do we
also have the special functions of
things like press on mesh
and that's really a judgment call
because the question you know like like
for that um
for the for the fitted region thing
you're not having a separate ransack
function
right that's ransack is just a method
what what
well i will argue that at least in the
descent that for that fitted right
general we are calling her john feet
you know ransack is so standard
techniques and so common like you have
in a linear regression
right
that's essentially the same similarity
when you do you know
fitting for region so that's the name
that's the brand that's the i understand
but we don't have a function called
ransack do we
it's a method
for
fitted region
or region fit or whatever right we don't
have that function so the question is
you're saying that's an important brand
but then maybe we should have a function
for that although i do not think we
should
but then the question is is concave hull
or alpha shape
important enough that it gets its own
function or is it just a method for
fitted region
fitted mesh is that the same level has
con convex you know convex whole mesh
dylan image
no it's not
no it's not
no it's not it's depend on the community
and what you're doing i mean stevens
what i mean you know if yes because
that's the point that's the judgment
call right the law and eye meshes are
something people you know
regularly talk about in a somewhat more
general way
i mean it's like in the neural net world
you know in the neural net world there
are people for whom
you know every different
weird configuration of
whatever's is a network that is their
personal friend
i mean i i think that the the real
difference i think between like the
llanoy mesh and this would be that like
a delanoy mesh like
a delanoy mesh is the product like it's
not like i'm trying to reconstruct a
mesh yeah there is no other way of
referring to what this lanai mesh is
other than by saying it's a delanoy mesh
and also it's a building block for many
other things right very infrequently is
that the end goal usually that's just
like
something you're computing along the way
but this is like you know i want to
reconstruct a mesh okay i'm going to use
this method for it
it's exactly the same as con i mean i
won't argue with that but it's
essentially the same as you know concave
whole mesh i mean when you're in that
community and the way it was coming from
there's no obvious for me there's no
difference between the lonely mesh
and now but what the point what
christopher is making is
one thing is the goal is to get a mesh
but it's not it's
not
so so
what we're saying is that the brand of
voronoi and delaney
is long established
and they have certain special properties
those meshes have certain special
properties which are relevant when
they're used as building blocks for
additional things
other kinds of meshes like these concave
you know hull meshes or whatever
probably don't have those special
properties they're just oh i've got a
good mesh now i can go use it for
something else no they do have
properties that's the thing the point is
that you know people introduce it
because you you know
properties that i'm there are two kinds
of properties one is properties coming
in and the other one is going out
something like a voronoi diagram has
properties coming out that are useful
for the next thing in the pipeline
which aren't just oh i got this these
regions out of this you know cloud of
points
whereas
for other things it's just like once
i've got a region i don't really care
where that region came from doesn't it
you know there there are mathematical
properties
that
of that output that are beyond just it
is some kind of mesh type thing
does that make sense
i mean are there properties of this
concave hull mesh
you know a convex hull there are many
properties for example there's no point
outside the convex hull
right that's an important property
there's no point that is you know
whatever it is i don't know what you
know when you
i guess the thing the the thing is
though i mean with with maybe with
complex homeless but definitely with
voronoi mesh and delano mesh you know
the whole point is those properties
right the mesh itself is almost like who
cares because it's just that you're
going to you're going to use that output
and given that you know the properties
of these types of meshes you're going to
use that to compute something else
but with this you know even if there are
some special nice mathematical
properties of say you know
mesh or whatever
it may be that 90 percent of people that
use it just don't care they just want a
mesh that looks kind of like you know
i think they're sort of those are the
two cases i mean i think that there are
casual users
that just want a mesh and fitted mesh is
great
okay the automation
then there are things
then there are the use cases where
people want a specifically a delaney
mesh no no no not the lawn ideal one is
a special case as this convex hull yeah
yeah because those things have no no
outward facing properties right yeah
that's my question does pasomas have
outward facing properties
you see what i'm saying
what are they
you know i mean the whole the whole game
here right is essentially you know how
long the object has been established and
how many applications no it's not that
no it's not that charles i'm making a
different definition here okay the
different definition is this this one
thing is what is the brand of fit okay
that's one thing okay but the other
thing is what are you going to use the
fit for if the fit has the properties
an interpolation is different from a fit
it's useful to know that something is an
interpolation because you know it goes
through all the points right right for
example
does it
are all the points inside
for example the question material you
can defense you say we don't know
do we know or don't we know caught on
for concave wholemeals yeah i think all
the points are inside yeah i think so
too
or all the points inside
charles what's the answer to that
when you see all the points inside
yeah
there's no point
in this picture when alpha is small
enough you end up with an empty set
right there is those type of property
you have i mean because it's the size of
the ball so if the essentially when you
think about it but when you construct it
i think that all the points are in fact
inside you have the case of the empty
set where the concave hole will give you
an empty set whenever it's visible
enough because the ball as long as the
ball is smaller than the
the mean size this you know the smallest
as long as you can have a ball a small
ball enough which covers all the points
but doesn't cover two of them
you get an empty set
right if you you can have disconnected
this can return a disconnected mesh
if the alpha is tiny every point is its
own component right well naturally it's
empty because actually when you think
about
is it is always connected
no
no
so essentially when you think about it
you know really roughly speaking you you
build a delaney mesh and then you cover
those mesh with balls
and you just take the edges where you
know to point and inside those balls
that's pretty much the base idea
so if you really think about it that
means in some cases you'll have empty
sets
or you'll have this connected object and
the reason it's an empty set is because
a single point on its own with us it
needs to have something that it can be
meshed to so to speak exactly in that
radius of the light bulb like so
well okay i know this is very relevant
for persistent homology stuff although i
think you would need to keep the
the you would not let the points wither
but that's this is off topic
yes
well but okay but the question i i guess
i mean
about the pulsar mesh stuff i don't know
i mean like for example when i look up
paul solomesh all the things i find
everything but one link calls it a
surface reconstruction which kind of
makes me think that it's like you know
the end goal is to get a surface
reconstruction not to get some mesh with
certain extremely specific properties
that only this mesh has
i i think that these things i think
it should be called i think what should
happen is this should be they should
both be fitted mesh this should be
method our poisson another one the other
one should be method arrow either alpha
shape or concave hull
and both of those names for the method
should be supported
that would be my suggestion and the and
the third method is whatever method is
first list surface plot 3d what is that
method what is that method called
they say
there's no method i think what's uh list
surface plus 3d is doing is just
computing the
send this sense function and when you
have the send distance function it does
a contour you know you call you know
list contour plot 3d okay so then we
could call it contour
that method could be called contour
does that make sense
and then hold on what what is the
function that returns primitives called
again
fitted region
and what's this one called fitted mesh
mesh
since it does return
definitively returns a mesh
i mean it's a little weird because you
know you you know meshes are also
regions but i guess
i guess that works
well at least we have any other
functions where there's a region version
and a mesh version and this is kind of
what happens
what do what is
well we we have you know convex
whole mesh and convex whole region but
where it's you know
what is convex whole region
it's the thing that can compute the
convex hole of any
region like a disk should be a disk
right yeah the convex hole of a disk is
a disk it's a disk
i see so it symbolically computes it
rather than returning a mesh
sometimes it returns a mesh object
because it needs to approximate right
we don't have you know that's
yeah
it needs to
so it's a little weird though because it
that the first usage of convex whole
region is just convex mesh is it not
i'm looking at the documentation if you
get a list of points the convex hole is
the same as convex well so we can do the
same thing here i mean fitted region
could allow as one of its quotes
primitives mesh
so fitted mesh is what you do if you
know that you want to have
a mesh as output
you know you want that approximating
mesh
and fitted region is what you do if you
you know if you you might be forced into
having look the default for a fitted
region well a fitted region has no
default
presumably a fitted mesh has a default
automatic thing that generates a mesh a
fitted region you would normally be
telling it what kind of region to fit to
right
although i have to admit fitted region
yeah i mean it's sort of okay if it just
insists on a second argument and you
tell it i want a mesh i want a circle i
want whatever that doesn't seem terrible
to me
and you could also you could say you
want a convex hull
as the fitted region
well i guess okay if that last thing
exists
well i i'm sort of i'm wondering i mean
why does convex hull mesh exist if
convex whole region also exists
i'm just you know if that's a mistake
then we don't want to make the same
thing here
yeah why does it right well one for us
was the precedence but we first had
convexol mesh because he was you know he
was part of that you know sub-system of
mesh and then we extended it
for all a bit traffic right jump so
right i mean is there a reason like
you know should it be
just fitted region
here but then you are you are mixing two
things that's what i'm trying to say
here
we want to do surface reconstruction and
then we want to do fitting it's two
different goals because fitting assume
you may have outlier you have noisy data
we have technique to fix that when you
you do surface reconstruction there is
you know that level of noise is not the
same and the technique you use are
different so merging those two
right we are just merging two different
goals from fitting a surface
reconstruction into one thing
how about reconstruction mesh or
reconstructed reconstruction mesh
reconstructed
since you've been well
yeah i understand but but the the reason
for not reconstructed it's kind of a
crazy name because why is why do you
think there was anything there to begin
with
you see what i'm saying reconstructed is
yes if you've got a point cloud
of a thing
i mean you're assuming that there is a
source for the point cloud
you could take approximating mesh or
something
i think that's obscure though i mean
it's so different
yeah but actually i like reconstruction
so i i don't want to
sour asana i think it's a pretty good
name
because i think it will be
recognized a lot
okay so then that would be the thing for
concave hull
mesh and poisson mesh
and also the surface plot
mesh
and then the other one will be called
fitted region
and that would be fitting to a region to
a specialized region
right
that makes kind of sense
um
the only thing okay region
it's okay yeah it's okay i mean given
you say what type of region it is
um
okay reconstruction mesh or
reconstructed mesh we're not mesh the
construction no it should end with mesh
really you know it's fabulous you know
surface reconstruction mesh
reconstruction
i'm sorry you get used to the name i
mean it's it's
okay yeah it really should end with mesh
given what about
construct i mean well what's actually
what what's the logic between when we
use verbs versus nouns
there is no logic
well it's the logic is attempting to be
a noun is a
thing that could be symbolic
and a verb
is
when you know it's going to compute
something yes
then can it be reconstruct mesh
for some reason because the mesh is such
a i mean it's such a symbolic thing
itself that doesn't feel quite right i
mean you know
a verb when it produces an answer like
13 or something the verb makes perfect
sense
when the thing that is happening
produces something that is itself
symbolic well it's not even clear it did
in a thing don't we have a repair mesh
yes
okay
not repaired mesh
what does repair mesh do it repairs it
this is for 3d printing i think yeah
like that was the main user
that that takes a mesh and returns a
mesh yes
this takes points and returns mesh does
that make a difference
i prefer reconstruction mesh
construction surface because people
always say recon surface reconstruction
right
yes
that is the process of reconstructing
meshes i don't know i i think
reconstruction meshes sounds especially
weird to me like it sounds like it
should at least be reconstructed mesh
well but the whole point is that it is
it is the mesh that is the
reconstruction
it's a similar thing to like the the
feature extraction
future extract or feature extracted you
know whatever i mean
the the
tion ending kind of sounds like it's
going to produce a function that that's
going to uh you're going to use many
times or something yeah okay fair point
well
i don't like reconstruct mesh
particularly given repair mesh
i have to say because surface
reconstruction
you know with that form is is such a
common
um
i think we should try living with
reconstruction mesh see how we like it
yeah well for the
livestream saying why reconstruct rather
than construct
um yeah well right that was but that's
what it's called it's called surface
reconstruction not con that's why i
prefer
reconstruction because it is sort of a
brand of thing rather than reconstruct
because there wasn't anything to
construct it from to begin with i think
the idea is that there was some you know
you're only going to run this when there
was some underlying surface
and then it got sampled into a bunch of
points and i know to reconstruct it i
know but it wasn't the original surface
right that is the that is the meta
concept i think
but
i'm favoring reconstruction mesh i i i
unfitted region
that would be my suggestion let's try
and see whether we can get through the
other things here but that's that would
be my suggestion what what is the name
going to be for the option that gives
the size of the alpha ball
that's only applicable to concave whole
mesh
so it has to be a method sub option
in this
i wouldn't do it that way that's really
obscure let's at least have it be a top
level method option and it just is
ignored for the other methods
is tolerance a reasonable option name
the reason yeah reasonable option name
but tolerance have a different meaning
tolerance has different meaning in every
time it's used and we need to actually
mount an effort to document what
tolerance means better
but isn't it like threshold or something
fitted region we have a tolerance yeah
what does it mean
we need to explain it
yeah doesn't it mean essentially the
same thing as these alpha balls
um no the alphabet is that alpha is
really part of the parametrization it's
not part of the tolerance what you know
like infinite region the tolerance is
more there
yeah okay
that far off basically tolerance is it
can be that far off and we'll ignore it
being that far off exactly
that's like a numerical approximation
epsilon kind of thing right it's going
to be some tiny number
yes
but as opposed to
the size i mean what is the right
description of the size of this ball
this is this is the same thing that will
be used for house stuff dimension
estimators and things like that so
actually wait first first question
though is it is it actually the radius
or is it one over the radius
it's surely got to be the radius if it's
not the radius there's something
horribly wrong
it is the radius isn't it charles
it's one of the reasons
we can't be one over the radius in our
design in our design is the radius if we
define alpha shape it should be a one
over the radius well it shouldn't let's
not have it one over the radius well
let's not call it alpha then for god's
sake yeah we don't call it our first
shift sounds good no but
that's not just alpha yeah right no no
okay so what's the name and what other
functions have this kind of thing so
this is essentially it's covering a
region hasn't this happened in other
region functionality you're covering it
with balls of some kind right
isn't that doesn't that come up in in
the uh um
mesh
uh what was that called um the the the
um
region mesh
connectivity graph doesn't doesn't
something like this come up in mesh
control no no no
where else does it come up this thing
about covering things with balls
top of my head i don't think we have a
function where we have
any type of covering or parametrization
of that salt in terms of reconstruction
well if that's if that's the case then
maybe we need a thing here that is
called something like
i mean maybe we should be very specific
coloring ball radius
i mean if it were an argument it would
just be r and it would be the radius
right
yes
i don't know it sounds it's like i i'm
not sure what i mean sure there are
there are other methods that that
involve uh
you know putting a bunch of balls over
the region but i don't know if they're
always covering balls or something like
that and also the balls don't i don't
i don't think they necessarily cover
like as in recovery
so like what's your point out if you
merge all this in one function right
that parameter we are
then covering ball cannot apply to all
methods then you have to be
no it doesn't have to be a sub option it
can be an option which is ignored for
the other methods oh okay
reconstruction mesh and then it's the
points
that's it
and ops
yeah i know it's opt but but the
question is
there might be form you know it's like
you might want other properties out of
it and stuff but we even if we don't
have them now we should
think that look this thing is some kind
of granularity it's some kind of what is
the general name for this kind of
concept
it's not quite tolerance something
similar to tolerance but it's not quite
tolerance
what you could talk about in terms of
the algorithm where it's like a radius
or you can talk about in terms of the
result where it's like a feature size or
a granularity or something yeah that's
that's right it's some kind of feature
size if we were going to do
min feature size or something
yeah what's the what's the thing called
for a meshes that they for for
triangulate mesh for example
uh
the screen the max cell measure yeah
next cell measure okay that's a bit
different
what is the difference between max cell
measure and and this
or min is there a min
measure
what the heck is that
that is
just
it allows you to control the
discretization
how fine it's going to get
which is kind of the same concept as
this it's a little bit complicated if
you go into it
i've no doubt like it could take a
function as it's it can yeah because it
can vary over the region and it can it
can be as a function of you know what is
like how long is the longest side versus
what's the area of the cell versus right
but it's i mean
this is
you know like many of these
approximation techniques triangulation
is a is an art
you know how pointy can the try i mean
this is is this does this address how
pointy the triangles can get no
but we run the
the triangulation methods that we use
guarantee certain level of quality
that this one does not
reject
what is it's not necessarily bad quality
to have a long nose triangle oh oh it is
yeah
it's intense the use right yeah but but
for the users we have you know like
finite element it is bad
okay but fine but so but but so we're
not parametrizing all right so we need
some option here
i think this is a more i mean in my use
of
these surface reconstruction things i
can tell you that i have always ended up
experimenting with that with that
granularity parameter
it essentially never works automatically
yeah i can believe that you know uh yeah
and particularly when you're
reconstructing things with these you
know graph embeddings and so on which
are kind of weird objects that aren't
really surfaces
i mean that's a great example of where
surface reconstruction is what you would
call it
but in fact there's nothing to
reconstruct because there wasn't a
surface to begin with
um
okay so
what is the what is the kind of i mean
it's a feature size it's a
there's got to be some other place where
we have an analogous situation
processing machine learning is there
some place
i mean i think cell
cell cell size you know is kind of what
you
try the cell size is like a million
things uh
but it's a radius
well i mean that's the question it's a
radius if you're thinking about it in
terms of how does the algorithm work
which is would be nice if you want to
explain how you know what this is in the
details and options but you know if
you're just thinking about
if you're just thinking about in terms
of the result
then it's just your size but i mean
again it would be nice probably if you
can document that oh yes you're not
going to have any edges that are shorter
than
the feature size or something like that
well is that what it looks like maybe
it's the men
i see you're saying
i don't know okay why don't you guys
think about this we're gonna need to
come back to it sure
um
oh boy
look at all this stuff yeah it's gonna
take us one more round for sure well
but i mean we've got hold on a second
let's just see what the calendar
situation is here
um
we were about to go on doing video what
was the what was the big thing we'd run
into a video here
there was a big issue we'd run into
uh we're in sort of video generation
mode
um i know that you wanted john fultz and
christina bateman there for the yeah
she's they're gonna be there for the
first hour for the player the ui for the
player
all right let's just have a quick look
at what else you've got here and that
means that they have been waiting now
probably yes
for their full hour
yeah well
that's what happens these things are
complicated what can i say
um
okay hold on
the
how much how
complicated is this
it's not complicated those two are not
complicated
the only thing that you're going to be
wanting to spend time on is to
understand congruent and similar
well
i'll probably discuss you know region
transformed me to expect to find
geometric transform oh yeah yeah right
that one too
yes
oh
yippee doodle doo
does this really work
3d version you said the exact same
thing
okay okay okay that's that's um
uh
oh boy
okay we finally got a a symbolic
language for lighting
that's a good thing as opposed to these
weird list things
is that right
yes
that's a good thing
even a spotlight isn't
yeah it's good that's nice okay
okay well we got to reschedule this for
another at least another hour
yep um and then let's switch now i guess
to the video stuff
does that make sense
okay i'm going to are we on the same
we're going to be using the same
uh
live stream and so on it's different
meeting okay all right then i'm i'm okay
let's okay people who are who are
following the live stream we will go to
a different live stream because we'll
have a different title and nobody will
ever find it if we if we leave it with
the same title
and so i am going to do i need to send
you this notebook or do you have
everything you need from this notebook
i assume the notes are going to come out
yep i'll send out some notes and there's
a recording
um
you can send me the notebook just to be
safe stephen
and i'll send it out okay
thank you
um there's a lot of very nice stuff here
guys this is really good
um
and i look forward to seeing the
remainder of it here
uh
okay all right well let's switch to the
other other thing and we'll see people
um back in a few minutes
okay